Ukraine says at least seven people have
been killed and more than 50 injured
after a Russian strike on a market in
the southern city of Herson
President Vladimir zielinski condemned
the attack saying there were no military
facilities located in the area he has
warned that Russia could be planning
more attacks during the holidays the
Kremlin has previously said there are no
plans for a ceasefire during this period
I'm very pleased to welcome Ukrainian
security expert Maria avdiva in Kiev
Maria want more can you tell us about
this attack on Harrison
they attacked happened today in the
morning when during the holiday a lot of
people were on the streets and it is a
crowded City Center where people did
their Christmas shopping and during the
attack a lot of them were there and so
for now we know that seven people were
killed and more than 50 injured 17
people are in critical condition so the
number of the victims of this attack
might grow and we know that Russia was
selling the city center of her soul with
great multi-rocket Launchers from the
other Bank of the nibro river which is
so close to the city Curson is
considered to be a front line itself and
there is no way how to warn people of
the upcoming attack because the Russian
positions are so close to the city
itself so this brutal attack as people
are going about their Christmas shopping
with no ceasefire inside what have
people in Ukraine been told that they
should expect during this holiday period
a president Polo Demar zelinsky and
other officials warned the Ukrainian
that they should be prepared for new
attacks in the upcoming weeks during the
Christmas and the new year and for
example here in key where I am now still
the electricity shutdowns are in place
and people have power outages still and
today only in Kiev two times we had air
raid alert and it means that people had
to go to the bomb shelters to hide and
of course this marks the Christmas
season for everyone in Ukraine people
are not celebrating but they are trying
to have at least some count time with
their families which we we don't know if
it will be possible because Russia is
for sure planning new attacks we know
that in the Black Sea uh the uh caliber
missiles that have the Russian warships
have on them are now deployed so the
attack might happen any of these days
and president zielinski has just
returned from the United States where
he's been promised additional support I
want to ask you about Europe's role what
is the view from Kiev is Europe doing
enough to support Ukraine
well we all hope here that after the
United States and now the new uh the new
Hub the new package of military aid and
also the deployment of patriot system in
Ukraine uh the uh European allies will
also do more because for now Ukraine
doesn't have time to wait we need to
push and we need to fight because
otherwise this time will be used for
Russians to regroup and attack Ukraine
again so more weapons are critical for
Ukraine meaning more tanks more
artillery and what is very important
more air defense Germany is supplying
Ukraine with a very uh very much needed
irisd and gear Parts but more is needed
because the territory is large and it's
not enough to defend all Ukrainian
cities and that is what Russians aiming
at to attack these cities attack
civilians and attack civilian
infrastructure
well thank you so much Maria abdifa and
Kiev we really appreciate you taking the
time to speak with us today
thank you